la ministre des sports oksana
maracineanu est venue symboliquement
posé sa pierre à l'édifice au centre
casse talia ce lundi 6 décembre héritier
de l'ancienne piscine de maurepas fermer
en 2015 ce centre aquatique aujourd'hui
dans la phase importante de la pause des
bassins est pensé et dimensionné pour
répondre à tous les besoins des
habitants c'est toujours un plaisir pour
moi donc ministre des sports et ancienne
nageuse olympique de venir voir comment
une piscine va sortir de terre un lieu
où on pourra apprendre à nager on pourra
se détendre également puisque on aura
fitness sera du sauna hammam et puis de
l'activité pour s'amuser puisqu'il y
aura de beaux grands numérique bref un
équipement qui soit adaptée à tous les
centres aquatiques sur un territoire et
l'équipement public qui réunit toutes
les générations
véritable projet structurant pour le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
un objectif ressort du lot lutter contre
les noyades chez les jeunes il y a mille
décès par an par noyade et le quart
concerne les enfants de moins de 6 ans
il faut qu'on agisse au plus près des
familles un espace construit dans une
logique de transition écologique avec
des matériaux durables et responsables
et un bâtiment intégré dans son
environnement penser développement
durable de penser transition énergétique
et cet équipement à la fois ce conte est
compact sa filtration billes de verre
c'est qu'on n'aura pas les désordres de
l'équipement passé le fait aussi d'avoir
un partenariat avec récré à une
délégation de service public le
partenaire aura l'obligation
d'entretenir et de faire les travaux sur
l'équipement pendant 25 ans un centre
aqualudique innovants pour petits et
grands qui devrait ouvrir en septembre